-So, this show "A.P. Bio" --
full disclosure,
because I love this show,
but I am one of the producers
on this show, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy that you are
playing this role.
You are playing a teacher who --
we sort of set it up
in the clip --
but you are not a good person.
Would you say that's accurate
on the show?
-Yeah. I'd say that's
pretty accurate, yeah,
or at least I'm trying not to be
a good person.
I think the secret sauce
to the show is that
he is extremely selfish
and narcissistic,
but ultimately, and I think
the creator, Mike O'Brien --
-Yes, a fantastic writer.
-He's amazing. He was on "SNL"
for six years as a writer.
And he's created a character
who puts on this front
of being extremely selfish
and narcissistic,
but I think under it all
there is some heart there,
but yeah, he basically
goes into classes and says,
"I'm not going to
teach you anything.
This is a free period for you,
and if you do
what I tell you to do
and don't try to make me
teach you biology,
then I'm going to
give you all an A."
Which I think is --
To most classes that would be
like a sweet deal,
but these kids --
and this is part of what makes
the show so different --
is these kids actually
want to learn something,
and that's a problem for me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to
have to do work.
-You offer them
Advil or Tylenol PM.
You actually give them a chance
to just take a pill
and fall asleep for an hour.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it's basically what you
would want your teachers
to do when you were in school,
but not these kids.
-Did you have important teachers
in your life?
Were you someone who --
-Uh, hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Important teachers?
-Yeah, that sent you
on your path?
I mean, you ended up
going to Juilliard.
-I did.
-So obviously something happened
in high school
that made you think,
"Oh, I should be an actor.
-Yeah, I wouldn't say --
I didn't have any, like,
"lean on me" type teachers.
Any "stand by me's."
-You didn't have a "lean on me"
or a "stand by me"?
[ Laughter ]
-Stand by me?
I had no one by me, basically.
I didn't have any teachers
who like, turned my life around
or anything like that.
But, no I tell you, there --
There was this one teacher
that I loved,
and he was my health teacher.
I think his name was Coach Scott
'cause he was also
the football coach.
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-The health teacher is never
just the health teacher.
He's always something else.
-I think my health teacher was
also our football coach, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, I don't get that, really.
I think he was, like,
the offensive line coach
but also the health teacher,
because I mean, who better to
teach you about, you know,
your budding human sexuality
than an obese high school
Alabama football coach.
[ Laughter ]
He's the one you want teaching
you about your body
and all the feelings
you're feeling.
-I feel like back in the day
health teacher
was a different thing.
It was like,
"Who knows how to do squats?"
But then it became more about
like sex ed,
and it took a while
for people to adjust
as to who should be
the better teacher there.
-Yeah, and it seems like
that's based on
where you are in the country,
right?
Because in Alabama, it's like,
we have to talk about sex,
but we really don't want to
talk about sex,
but we should,
but we can't, and we will.
So listening to this man
try to explain
the secondary sex
characteristics of a female
was very uncomfortable.
-But you had
a very interesting upbringing.
Your dad was in the Air Force,
so you traveled
all around the world.
-Yeah.
-And then ended up
in high school in Alabama.
What was -- By the time you got
to high school, like,
was your international
experience,
did that make you ready for
an American high school,
or not ready for
an American high school?
-No, not --
I would say not ready.
I mean I -- because most of the
schools I'd gone to were --
they were like --
they were military schools.
So other kids
were always coming in,
and everybody was, like, "Hey,"
and welcoming each other,
but when I moved to Alabama
everybody had been there
and grown up together.
So, you know,
I just felt like a real dork.
You know, I was like,
"Hey, nice to meet everybody,"
and everyone was, like,
"No, who are you?"
Like, "Get out of here."
-Did you at least like --
Was it true you were in Korea
for a while?
-Yeah, yeah.
-So did you at least know what
American pop culture was
or American style?
-We had like one American
station on the TV,
so I knew
"Jeopardy!" and cartoons.
[ Laughter ]
But no, I mean, my parents were,
first of all, they're not --
I love them,
they're such wonderful,
wonderful people,
but they weren't, like, hip.
You know what I mean?
So they were like going --
And my mom's so cheap.
So we would go to this Korean
market called Itaewon,
and she would buy us, like,
the cheapest knockoff,
like, members only.
The velcro sneakers,
so basically when I showed up
to school in Alabama,
everyone had their whatever was
cool in Alabama,
their polo shirts, and I had
like, a guy on the horse,
But it wasn't.
-Right.
-It wasn't the right guy.
[ Laughter ]
He wasn't playing polo.
I don't know what he was doing.
He was playing
a different sport.
-It was a weird horse.
It didn't have four legs,
it had like three legs.
'cause they -- you know,
'cause of copyright things.
So, yeah, I was wearing clothes
from like a different decade.
It was bad.
-That's fantastic.
I'm glad everything worked out
for you,
and you found a place where
you're comfortable and happy.
The woods.
-In the woods.
Where you can survive
in the woods.
-That's right.
-Thanks so much for being here.
I'm so excited for the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I am so happy
to be working with you.
Glenn Howerton, everybody.